martine lafon et son mari sont
végétariens et c'est à cause de leurs
deux garçons c'est un ragoût de
lentilles courgettes sur lit de conches
baguette 6 à 6 ans nathan a cessé de
manger de la viande on voyait les
canards dans lac puis ma mère manger un
sandwich au canard et flashy fait le j
ai demandé si c'était les mêmes qu'un
mort qui avait dans la cave est dans sa
logique plus béat leur répondit oui le
végétarisme de nathan n'a duré qu'une
semaine
j'aimais beaucoup de choses avec de la
viande mais l'été suivant c'est au tour
de son frère maxence de s'inquiéter du
sort des animaux assurent les animaux
souffrent qui ont les yeux pour faire la
viande avec et ils m'ont répondu oui et
mais je trouvais ça injuste
mon conjoint et moi on fait regarder
pour la venue la semaine prochaine
serait terminée mais ça fait un an et
neuf mois pire jamais retoucher un
morceau de viande est vraiment vraiment
déterminé depuis le reste de la famille
a délaissé la viande à la maison ils
mangent davantage de poissons et de
légumineuses l'enregistrement au québec
de plus en plus d'enfants et
d'adolescents décide de devenir
végétarien ou même végétalien pour point
de vue de l'alimentation végétarienne si
tout à fait possible mais je dis tout le
temps mes patients que un peu on doit en
discuter avec le médecin pour s'assurer
qu'on sait exactement quoi faire
et puis b vraiment s'assurer que
l'enfant a assez de protéines et de fer
cette nutritionniste diététiste
accompagne des adolescents qui adoptent
le végétalisme dans leur assiette pas de
viande ni de poisson ni deux ni de
produits laitiers qui se suppléments en
vitamine b12
donc elle s'est vite amis qu'on retrouve
ce mercredi de source animale donc en
devient juge italien faut absolument se
supplémenter maxence n'en est pas rendu
là mais il a bien l'intention de
demeurer végétarien son grand frère est
fier de lui c'est que c'est difficile
pour lui je l'aï déjà vécu fait qu'ai je
trouve ça je trouve ça vient ici
marie-eve cousineau raid au canada c'est
lambert